this winter's easily been one of the
best anime seasons in recent times with
the return of mob psycho 100 and some
really great non sequels like the
promised Neverland doral rising of the
shield hero and loads more will the
spring season of anime be just as good
let's find out they're all gonna be out
in April so get ready for them
we kick off with a bang or in this case
a punch with one punch man season 2
everyone's favourite bald hero Saitama
comes back with more epic punches
alongside his devoted cyborg sidekick
Geno's familiar faces like silver Fang
tornado of terror and speeder sounds
sonic also reappear in the upcoming
season plus a new foe takes center stage
one who dares to challenge Saitama
strenght and reputation as the fabled
one punch man
this season is sure to be a knockout so
get your fists ready next up it's the
remake of fruits basket we're going down
memory lane with this one and for anyone
who doesn't know fruits barsky it was a
short-lived anime back in 2001 about
thorugh Honda the housekeeper to the
soma clan they took her in after finding
her camping on their private property a
circumstance that Toru was forced into
as she's an orphan members of the family
have the ability to turn into animals of
the Chinese zodiac when hugged by
someone of the opposite sex now I know
it's weird to have Japanese characters
turn into something from the Chinese
zodiac but they didn't see an issue with
this when they made the anime almost two
decades ago and they don't have an issue
doing it again what kind of differences
can we expect in the remake well we'll
have to wait and see in April
now we have Ken John Oh Margo this anime
sees a young man a reincarnated as a
baby after dying in an accident now
after being revived the Patriot hero
Merlin wolf had picked up the child and
raised him as his grandson naming him
shin now over the years Merlin trains
him in the fine arts of magic and shin
soaks up every single lesson now that's
all well and good except for one little
thing by the time machine turns 15
Merlin realized he forgot to teach his
adoptive grandson the most important
thing every magic practitioner requires
common sense so yeah I think it's safe
to say that many shenanigans will happen
in this one
next up is the second core of attack on
Titan season 3 easily being one of the
most watched anime this is an anime that
everyone knows about now the show left
off where Titans have taken over the
outer wall Maria and they must plug in
the hole the colossal Titan made to take
back their land to help with
overpopulation and food shortages and
ending the third season with radical
plot twists what will happen next is the
main protagonist ventures off into Titan
territory in an attempt to save humanity
as they know it
this season promises a lot more action
so be prepared for a big roller coaster
ride
jiya huasteca career Atacama its own
Gina you got sir
moving on then it's demon slayer commit
zone oh yah
now before I mention this one I highly
suggest you get some tissues and I mean
the good kind with a lotion in them
because this is a real tearjerker set in
an old era of Japan humans have been
plagued by rumors of man-eating demons
roaming throughout the woods late at
night now as you can imagine the town's
folk don't dare leave the safety of
their homes after dark but for our
protagonist a young boy named tan Jiro
these are more than just rumors it all
started when he took over the role of
provider for his family after the death
of his father
while the family suffered much tragedy
they make the most of what they have in
a relatively happy then one day the
happiness is destroyed I don't want to
say any more because I think it's one of
those shows where you should just go in
there blindly and check out yourself
it's made by Studio offer table so
expect great animation and awesome
action scenes our next anime is gonna
ortho tamari right this one goes out to
you if you're musically inclined based
on the original manga of the same name
our hero Takezo is left as the sole
member of the koto Club after the senior
members graduate now a quick one for you
a quarter is a traditional Japanese
string instrument and with the new
school year looming Becky Zhou is
pressured to recruit new members or risk
the club being terminated well would be
scrappy new member barges in through the
door of the practically empty Club and
demands to join so while turkeys OHS on
the path of reviving the quarter Club
he'll have to deal with this rascal of a
new member is it really worth it to
avoid termination we're gonna have to
wait and see
[Music]
next up is bungle stray dogs season 3
for those who haven't heard about this
series it follows the members of the
armed detective agency who solve
mysteries and carry out missions for the
Mafia using their superpowers now for me
personally it's a very underrated series
I think a lot of people dropped it after
the first season because it was average
but the second season was pretty good so
if you haven't seen it do go and check
it out season 3 will feature the
underground organization rats in the
House of the Dead in its leader fjord or
so get yourself up-to-date with the
other seasons to get ready for them
cook
do delicately focus
[Music]
the next entry on the list is Shu
matsutake we all misplace things from
time to time it's a common thing isn't
it
one moment we've got the thing and then
the next it's disappeared however there
are some things you simply can't lose as
easily as a set of keys so how does a
whole freaking city brick by brick
disappear overnight in this anime Yuki
the only person left behind after this
masked vanishing tries to find out with
the help of lone wolf Takuya I buy the
contract courier it turns out a great
conspiracy is brewing and people with
mysterious and bad intentions are
lurking about so the pay go off to find
the city appropriately named lost by the
way and they bond with each other along
the way as their journey goes on
and now it's Shinichiro Watanabe his new
anime Carol and Tuesday 50 years have
come and gone since the day mankind
migrated to the final frontier in this
case the planet Mars
then there's Carol a teen who aspires to
become a musician and struggles to put
food on the table working part-time in
the bustling metropolis of Alber city
meanwhile in the provincial town of
Herschel City lives Tuesday a young lady
born into a wealthy family she too wants
to be a musician but no one around her
understands this ambition now a chance
meeting gives one girl what she's always
been missing while the other gets the
understanding that she never had
together they work hard to realize their
dreams of singing and sharing their
music with the world and finally the
last anime on the list is a Sarah's and
my well this one is a little bit ok ok
it's very weird bear with me on this one
okay the series centers around three
middle school buddies in their second
year now it's a normal day for the boys
when they meet an odd creature at Scapa
named kept be the heir to the throne of
the Kappa Kingdom or so they say at
least the next thing the boys know this
little self entitled water sprite steals
their [ __ ] ekodama now here's where it
gets a bit weird
just follow me on this Ashera Kodama is
a mythical organ that guffaws steal
through the anus of their victims my god
it sounds twice as weird saying it out
loud anyway
this causes the students to turn into
Capas themselves and get be with the
usual offer you can't refuse tells them
that if they want to return to their
former selves they need to connect in
that way and must bring him the [ __ ] or
Kodama
of zombies so now the boys have to steal
mythical organs from undead walkers if
they ever hope to be human again as if
puberty wasn't already screwing up these
kids you've got this going on as well so
he is hoping that they turned back to
normal when April rolls around and turn
kepi into Capra kebabs
well that's about it folks I hope you
enjoyed this video and are a stoked for
the spring season as I am don't forget
to like the video subscribe to the
channel and hit the bell notifications
so you'll be updated whenever I post
something new also feel free to drop in
on me on Twitter and follow at tavini
tube and you can also check out my
patreon account if you'd like to
contribute to this channel I'll leave
the links in the description below until
next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]